la politique française les militants du
Parti socialiste sont réunus
actuellement en université d'été à La
Rochelle les socialistes ont quelques
problèmes de stratégie présidentielle
puisqu'ils sont en fait suspendus bon gr
malgré à la décision de Jacques Delor
une incertitude qui inquiète qui voire
qui agace certains dirigeants
socialistes qui souhaitent préserver
l'autonomie de leur parti avant d'en
parler avec Henry emmanuellie en direct
de La Rochelle reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux Guilen Chenu et Alain locacio
sur l'état d'esprit des militants
socialistes cela devient une habitude
dès qu'ils se réunissent les socialistes
sont condamnés à faire parler les
silences ceux de Jacques de l'or bien
sûr personne ne sait encore s'il sera
candidat alors on s'interroge sur
l'homme et son
profil je crois que c'est un homme de
gauche il est peut-être moins affirmé
que d'autres mais je pense que c'est un
homme de gauche est-ce que ce sont les
sondages qui doivent faire la code de
popularité ou qu' doivent créer les
candidats je sais pas je sais qu'il y a
des règles à l'intérieur du parti qui
sont la désignation des candidats par
les militants les militants désigneront
leurs candidats certains ne veulent pas
se laisser imposer un candidat ni un
programme la question est d'importance
quel doit être le rôle du parti face à
Jacques Delor mais là c'est le monde à
l'envers on commence par les noms et
puis on discute après du contenu alors
dans dans ce parti il y a des gens on se
demande où on est on est passé du
candidat naturel au candidat surnaturel
celui-là on lu demande plus rien hein
notre rôle serait de passer nos journées
à lui demander s'il vous plaît monsieur
veuillez bien être candidat à quel
condition qui vous convient il faut que
ce soutienne avec un contrat un
candidatcques del est un socialiste il a
pas de
raisonop entre
Luis entre qui attendent jaqu comme un
sauveur et ceux qui veulent lui imposer
des conditions le débat n'est pas
tranché les socialistes on jusqu'au mois
de janvier pour y
réfléchir